ya hemos pasado bastante tiempo
reflexionando sobre estos seis
escenarios todos los cuales se
encuentran en la frontera de
posibilidades de producción que
significa que en cualquiera de esos
escenarios
hemos logrado la eficiencia de
producción y esto no se aplica sólo para
estos escenarios sino también para
cualquier punto que esté sobre esta
curva así que en cualquier punto de esta
curva tenemos logrado la eficiencia de
la productividad y esto significa que si
estamos en algún punto de esta curva y
quisiéramos más conejos por ejemplo
tendríamos que ceder bayas por ejemplo
si estamos en el punto ce y queremos más
conejos si quisiéramos un conejo más
tendríamos que cds o dejar de buscar
bayas o si estamos en este mismo punto
ce y queremos más bayas vamos a tener
que dejar de cazar al menos un conejo y
llegar al punto de y esto se cumple para
cualquier punto en esta curva de la
frontera de posibilidades de producción
cualquier punto por acá voy a ponerlo en
otro color imaginemos que en este
no se ha logrado eficiencia de
productividad porque podemos tener más
conejos sin tener que ceder ninguna
valla y llegaremos al escenario y ver o
podemos tener más bayas sin tener que
ceder ningún conejo y llegar al punto de
así que este punto de acá no es
eficiente es ineficiente ya tenemos que
en estos seis escenarios cumplimos con
la eficiencia de productividad pero cómo
vamos a elegir entre todos ellos como
decidimos ubicar nuestro tiempo así que
lo que quiero hablar en este vídeo es
acerca de la eficiencia de ubicación
eficiencia de ubicación
y eso es algo subjetivo ya que si
nosotros somos el cazador recolector
pues bueno va a ser con respecto a
nuestras preferencias pero al menos esto
nos ayuda a tener un marco de referencia
para ver cuáles de todos estos
escenarios coincide mejor con nuestras
preferencias y para hacer esto voy a
revisar un poquito lo que vimos en el
vídeo anterior en donde veíamos el costo
marginal de cada incremento en conejos y
vimos que el costo de oportunidad de
cada unidad incremental en realidad es
el costo marginal vamos a escribir estos
escenarios diferentes escribimos
escenarios y pensemos en el costo
marginal de conejos incrementales y aquí
sólo voy a dibujar un conejito un conejo
incremental que estará dado en bayas
en bayas comencemos con el escenario efe
y ese solo es un recordatorio del vídeo
anterior estando en el escenario efe si
queremos un conejo más vamos a tener que
ceder 20 bayas 20 en el escenario
queremos otro conejo más tendremos que
ceder 40 bayas así que el costo marginal
en ese punto de un conejo extra es de 40
bayas ahora en el escenario de y aquí
los invitó a que pausa en el vídeo y
hagan esos cálculos por su cuenta en el
escenario de el costo de un conejo extra
es ahora de 60 vallas
llegamos al escenario se en donde el
costo ahora es de 80 vallas llegamos al
escenario b y el costo de estar en el
escenario y tener un conejo más
tendremos que ceder 100 vallas y ya no
llego más allá del escenario ah porque
aquí ya no tengo más conejos que cazar y
ya no tengo vallas que sedes así que
estos son todos los escenarios posibles
con respecto al costo marginal vamos a
graficar estos en una línea en un eje
vamos a hacer espacio y voy a poner aquí
el eje este eje va a ser el de los
conejos en el escenario
efe no tengo ningún conejo aquí comienzo
con cero conejos luego sigo con un
conejo dos conejos tres conejos cuatro
conejos y cinco conejos así que aquí
están los conejos son los conejos que
podemos atrapar en promedio cada día y
en el eje vertical voy a tener el costo
marginal en cada uno de estos escenarios
el costo marginal expresado en bayas y
estas son las cantidades de bayas para
cada escenario
así que aquí cuando tengo 0 conejos y 20
bayas estoy en el escenario efe
cuando ya tengo un conejo tengo 40 bayas
y estoy en el escenario y aquí va a
estar el escenario de aquí el c
finalmente aquí estará el escenario b ya
tenemos cuatro conejos estamos pensando
en conseguir otro conejo más y tendremos
que ceder 100 bayas para lograrlo lo que
acabamos de hacer aquí es graficar el
costo marginal estos son puntos en
nuestra curva del costo marginal aunque
aquí coincidió que salió como una línea
pero no siempre es el caso ese es el
costo marginal en función de la cantidad
de conejos que tenemos pero aún no
sabemos cuál escenario elegir para
pensar al respecto quiero presentar un
concepto nuevo llamado beneficio
marginal lo voy a abreviar como bm y lo
escribo aquí como otra columna beneficio
marginal de conejos nuevamente expresado
en bayas
y la forma de pensar con respecto al
beneficio marginal es que si nosotros
somos los cazadores-recolectores y
estuviéramos en alguno de estos
escenarios cuanto pagaríamos a una
tienda de conveniencia hipotética en
bayas imaginando que esta tienda sólo
vende conejos y sólo acepta bayas cuando
se les pagaría en bayas por cada conejo
incremental o por cada conejo extra y
veamos esta columna de acá estamos en el
escenario efe donde no tenemos ningún
conejo vemos que en el escenario efe
tenemos 0 conejos y 300 vallas al no
tener ningún conejo y tener muchas
vallas pues podríamos decir que pagamos
bastantes vallas por un conejo digamos
que vamos a pagar 100 vallas por un
conejo le pagaríamos 100 bayas a esa
tienda de conveniencia hipotética para
comprar un conejo ahora si estuviéramos
en el escenario en cuanto le pagaríamos
a esta tienda hipotética bueno en el
escenario ya tenemos un conejo y tenemos
280 bayas así que no estamos dispuestos
a pagar
bayas por un conejo adicional quizás
solo vamos a pagar 80 vallas por ese
conejo extra ahora pasamos al escenario
de en donde ya tenemos dos conejos y
tenemos menos bayas así que estamos
dispuestos a pagar menos varias por ese
conejo adicional eso es lo que le
pagaríamos a esta supuesta tienda y esto
es con base en nuestras preferencias
actuales ahora vamos al escenario ce
esto no es algo fijo está basado en las
preferencias particulares de una persona
está basado en las preferencias
particulares de este cazador recolector
en el escenario tenemos ya tres conejos
y menos bayas nada más tenemos 180 bayas
así que pagaremos todavía menos
finalmente llegamos al escenario ve
donde aquí tenemos cuatro conejos y
poquitas bayas sólo tenemos 100 vallas
por lo que estará dispuesto a pagar
todavía mucho menos bayas sólo 20 bayas
por un conejo extra ahora graphic hemos
el beneficio marginal como función de
los conejos en bayas así que si estamos
en el escenario efe nuestro beneficio
marginal va a ser de 100 está hasta aquí
arriba en el escenario
nuestro beneficio marginal va a ser 80
por un conejo extra en el escenario de
tenemos 60 vallas en el escenario c
tenemos 40 vallas y en el escenario b
vamos a tener sólo 20 bayas donde ya
tenemos cuatro conejos así que ahora no
sólo estamos graficando el costo
marginal sino que también incluimos la
gráfica del beneficio marginal voy a
quitar esto para tener el espacio para
escribir a ambas costo marginal diagonal
beneficio marginal en bayas así que las
etiquetamos este es el costo marginal
y la curva del beneficio marginal va así
aunque no me quedo muy recta pero bueno
es esta donde unimos todos estos puntos
este es el beneficio marginal ambas como
función de los conejos que ya se tienen
teniendo todo esto que es lo que
racionalmente yo debo de hacer si esas
son mis preferencias que es lo que
debería hacer estoy aquí en la situación
f donde no tengo ningún conejo y es el
que me va a costar 20 bayas obtener un
conejo pero yo ya dije que estoy
dispuesto a pagar 100 vallas por un
conejo extra así que yo me quiero mover
a lo largo de esta curva en esta
dirección
definitivamente quiero tener más conejos
ya que dije que estoy dispuesto a pagar
100 vallas por algo que me costaría
conseguir 20 otra forma de ver esto
visualmente es que el beneficio marginal
es mucho mayor que el costo marginal así
que quiero intentar conseguir más
conejos eso también se cumple en el
escenario en donde el beneficio marginal
de tener un conejo extra es de 80 y el
costo marginal de obtener ese conejo es
de 40 el beneficio es mayor que el costo
así
en el escenario y aun quiero moverme
sobre esta curva de la frontera de
posibilidades de producción en esta
dirección que sucede conforme me voy
acercando a d en este escenario que
estoy un poquito antes de llegar a de mi
costo marginal va a seguir siendo menor
que el beneficio marginal así que aún
seguiré queriendo conseguir más conejos
hasta que llegó al escenario de en el
escenario de yair llegue a un punto
neutral quiero pagar 60 vallas por un
conejo y a mí me costaría igual 60 bayas
conseguir ese conejo por mi cuenta así
que pensemos en el escenario de como un
escenario especial lo voy a marcar aquí
ahora si queremos hacer algo más allá
del escenario de en este punto de acá e
imaginando que quisiéramos conseguir dos
y medio conejos tiene sentido para mí
conseguir más conejos después de este
punto
por ejemplo en este punto el beneficio
de un conejo incremental es menor que el
costo de conseguir ese conejo
incremental en este punto si quiero
conseguir otro conejo voy a tener un
beneficio menor de lo que
me está costando a mí conseguir ese
conejo así que definitivamente no me
conviene incrementar mis conejos más
allá del escenario de ya que en este
punto he logrado la eficiencia de
ubicación en donde mi costo marginal y
mi beneficio marginal son iguales así
que con base en la forma en la que
estableció los números en este ejemplo
queremos quedarnos en el escenario de en
donde logramos la eficiencia de
ubicación en donde el costo marginal
como función de los conejos es igual al
beneficio marginal en función de los
conejos